[Music]
20 international chess professionals
converge here in st. Louis for the 2017
winter chess classic hello chess fans
and welcome to the wrap-up report of the
2017 winter chess classic going into
today three players were eligible to win
in Group A in fact a two or three player
playoffs could have been possible in
Group E with Andre bearish bullets in
the lead all the Ukrainian had to do was
secure a draw and the victory of the
entire field was his after all other
games had finished only one remained
roofing Lee vs david howell if David
lost he is out said yo SE of and spirits
would go to a two player Armageddon
playoff if how old r uu then they would
go to a three-player Armageddon knockout
playoff 120 moves in David Howell
clinched of victory which meant no
playoffs necessary he takes group a we
have the winner Grandmaster David how
loved England he has been the
front-runner for most of this entire
tournament and today he finally put the
kibosh on it David how are you feeling
after winning in regulation I don't
think I've ever been more pumped this is
coming strange feeling I feel like
spacious smiled on me today in a way
because I mean so many things had to
kind of with such little margins so many
things had to go in my favor and I mean
I never dreamed when I woke up this
morning that will be this dramatic so
I'd be playing for six hours that I'd
even have a chance to win this woman so
I mean this has been probably the most
enjoyable weeks of my career as well I
just had the best vibe like in San Luis
and it's a good way to win this one is
this your first time playing in st.
Louis that's right yeah it's my first
time in the States for around ten years
so yeah I wanted to check out the scene
here for a while and well it's a shame
you didn't have a rest day to check it
out a little bit more I know I arrived
like three days in advance notice to a
climate
go to the jet lag and have a look around
and everyone so lovely here and a cargo
plane well I that's really great and
actually we are recording this just like
moments after this game is over so he's
still out of breath so let's do that is
right so this is I would need to set up
this game so you played roofing Lee the
very prominent us junior contender and
we were looking at possible playoffs
here so you if the situation was if you
lose then two other players have a
playoff if you draw three-way playoff if
you win then you get to go home not deal
with any of those playoffs and maybe the
latter option is what one so take us
through the game and we'll talk more
about it yeah I mean it was crazy i
thought okay obviously my phone was very
very promising strong player great
greatest tactics so here ya this is
whether unstarted just a question
whether i could win his poor when it be
five born or get him into making that
before the end of the 50 moves so
already when he played he five on the 52
I kind of realized that this might be 50
moves from Alvin is kind of the deadline
by when I have to do stuff to him now
for those of you who aren't familiar the
50 move rule is 50 moves by both players
so 50 full moves without a capture and
and with no pawn pushes or pawn
movements whatsoever so here's where it
starts yeah so if I this is lost pull
move very unlikely pieces are going to
be exchanged and so hard to exchange off
his dark squared bishop I think object
color bishops kind of give them a color
complex to at least hide is king on so I
knew no pieces would be exchanged just a
matter of checkmate a winner point and I
mean to be fair i'd kind of given up
hope a bit later on so when it can gets
out I mean already it's very difficult
here his nights coming around to a great
square and at six it's going to kind of
cut my king off already I can't come
back with the King so I kind of
committed it's going forward so here my
plan was a chat makes him on the edge
file but it's a seer didn't really work
out
yeah teen aged care for here maybe it's
slightly more accident but then I was a
bit scared he could run his King and I
nearly blundered some f5 machi 7 which
would be tricky please have yeah these
nights I mean so many Forks in every
position that often Lee can play t6 and
track Nissan fork so okay so here I was
pretty happy I thought I'd got him into
the edge of the board he can't really
wait with his bishop because it's [ __ ]
26 has to protect both spawns so he
can't wait with his bishop I thought if
he waited with his kingdom he might get
for stealing further towards the corner
but unfortunately he always seems to
have at least one waiting rooms to
survive I mean objectively I felt I
could have post more problems that may
be it is a draftable so okay around here
he put his knife in a fake creating a
strange kind of fortress as keeping my
king out so his king will always be safe
on g7 IH eight and here I i just wanted
to repeat moves I mean as you can see
out there should be three which way dude
trying to gain 30 seconds on the clock
but I realized after King gauge search k
h6 which might be a mistake Bishop cheap
labor ship g8 and suddenly he has no
waking was I mean if he if he moves to
the Knights and at least i can again
trusted some I mean everything's a draw
I mean I thought I could threaten come
check mate with King at four but he was
this is e six friday ok so i was just
playing for tricks around her I mean one
of my friends teases me about how I mean
this whole tournament has kind of been
tricking my way after bad position and
hear that my only hope really to set a
trap kind of give him a few chances to
go wrong so I mean putting the 28 again
it looks quite nice it looks like I'm
trappings king but it's his night covers
everything ok didn't work out on the G
file so I came around to the seventh
tried to persuade around but now his
King got out and I was counting down to
move 102 here which would be the 50 news
um system is true so okay I mean I was
just trying to cut his King off and hope
for the best I mean he kind of kept his
life in Essex which looks nice but here
it doesn't really help help if King
survive I mean it's get the checks
through and I mean okay critical moment
again I think he had blundered around
her just before I mean five six moves to
go before miss before the 15 yrs rule I
mean maybe he could just play should be
eight or move his King I mean my trap is
that Bishop p6 obviously fails to work
takes f6 and his opponent overloaded so
I was kind of trying to force him to
play Bishop d6 and here i think only now
he realized that Bishop d6 would fail
Bishop e2 and I forced his knights back
to Essex when I can take it and if it
goes back to g3 I have work at three
checks so I've kind of put his pieces on
the only possible squares where they are
actually vulnerable and I would just a
bit surprised he didn't cubits the
pieces all protected putting them on h5
and c7 just sell strange and okay
luckily I have this wish me to trick and
everything works out just in time check
yes and i took this porn on move 49 I
mean I was still well I was still pretty
sure that he might be able to draw with
best play but ok what's the momentum
changes once I've got that porn I mean
it's going to be so hard for him to kind
of mentally readjust and get back to
defending all over again from me 50 ok
so I repeat yeah how was angry at myself
again for repeating this just in case we
were back to another 50 movement and
here maybe king-sized mistake and he
realized after I played it so we heard
it I thought maybe he could take
brooksy 798 and okay I was pretty sure
he wouldn't play night baat 62 strange
but suddenly his night comes back before
he's got all sorts of kind of night
books again so if he gets my be porn
it's a draw I mean this should be
winning if i can get my route to a
better square so i can get my king
towards the Beast towards vporn but I
wasn't sure how I mean the only move I
can play to stop 94 is Richie seven
after King III suddenly keeps
threatening 94 again if I go rip dee
sighs it's another fork so if i go back
with my kingdom he comes forward and
suddenly he's I mean he's making program
so i was i was thinking maybe I even
have to play something a bit stars like
rookie seventh King somewhere and then
rupee six but Elysia some and then bring
my king across so easy has more
practical chances here maybe especially
with my clock much like hanging against
but ok so now his night without the
people and it no longer has any kind of
output his [ __ ] 25 is the only one
which well it wants to look spicy 50
pieces too that's ok i messed around a
bit here didn't even really know what I
was doing she's trying to risk readjust
I was just again I was trying to set
some traps so for example if he I mean
he nearly picked 83 here and then his
nights gets trapped at the side of the
board because if he goes 95 and I have a
similar trick right take a five if he
goes to be a then his night trapped so
ok eventually I kind of found a plan to
bring my king to d3 and once they get
here again he should have bought his
King to d2 so it's closer to running
away so at least he can come round this
way now and try and make way I mean
obviously come and we chat make him all
over again but his night is so bad here
in a five that I kind of felt it was
winning once my King gets the d3 it's
just all over i think his Kings traps
not just three and similar King c3 and
his bishops overloaded it can never move
from protectively before porn next we
move on going Bishop c4 and his King is
internet so yeah the game finished might
be three and twenty two and it's
checkmate or I'm winning this one game
so I mean it's still a bit of a blur to
me I know I'm talking so much gibberish
just it the untrained eye looks at
earrings and looks at this game they're
like well okay David's winning be a game
he's got this one in the back but that
is a tactical minefield so then all it
takes is one sick exactly I mean his
only mistake was at the worst possible
moment I mean he defended so well he saw
the tactics he settled the truck and I
mean and games up its underestimates
about all about calculation especially
in these kind of strange material and
balanced position engines can really
they don't really portray that lost
human I mean they are doing about
fortresses and this was kind of a sport
restore a lot of it though yeah happy to
her before I approach record you
mentioned that you were really really
not wanting it to go to acquire and I
said is in fact if it went to playoff
didn't know if you could stand a chance
eyes you say that sure I mean I think
some of the other games finished after
two and a half three hours I mean my
game finished six out I mean after six
hours just half an hour ago land lot one
in the room lost one in the room I mean
I was on increment for probably a
hundred after their conscience dirty
moves so yeah I know so a bit on end so
um I mean when I woke up this morning my
goal was to get a tie-break because I
realized i was half a point behind i
thought okay said if they have played it
safe makes a draw with white then i need
to win to get it there but after a game
like this I mean towards the end I was
determined that I had to just eat out
every little chance just because the
tiebreaker
nobody wrap it to my friend but well
here's a libel it's Armageddon oh yeah
yeah it's already extremely arturia Mike
comer was upstairs like rubbing his
hands together like oh yeah we're going
Armageddon yeah maybe he was sorry guys
I would have a thought for you and I was
not to be this time well David a bona
fide pro chess player what is next for
you next I've got some tournaments lined
up I will be playing in the European
individual championships and a couple of
months to try and qualify for the World
Cup I mean that's one thing I've never
done qualified for the world cup so
that's my goal very difficult in Europe
I mean we've only got this one qualifier
and often 200 gram losses will turn up
so and the 20 kala find places so we'll
see how that goes I mean long-term Mike
I don't try not set goals I try to just
enjoy it as it comes but I guess
reaching 2700 again would be good I mean
I felt I had a bit of a dip last year I
mean as soon as I get 2,700 it was kind
of a roller coaster back down again so
I'd like to kind of maintain that get
the most abilities in my play and I mean
just enjoy a bit more last year the
concert I was constantly traveling and I
think I got a bit while the lifestyle I
mean you know what chess is like the
last fells a bit tricky you have to keep
motivating yourself to wake up in the
mornings and especially when things
going badly it's difficult but that's my
goal to
enjoy well I think that's a great
outlook and David congratulations again
man died was an awesome the sign
frontrunner for most of the tournament
here he is England's grand master David
how the champion of the 2017 winter
chess classic group a there was a
three-way tie for fourth place so Sam
shankland alexander ii tov and yarrow
Zira book will share one thousand dollar
fourth place prize just short of making
that playoff coming in at second place
with five and a half points tied
vladimir fitter sieve and darius spirits
these two players will split five
thousand dollars which is the sum of the
second and third-place prizes and your
group a champion david howell of England
five grand in his name he looks forward
to future tournaments coming right back
here to the st. Louis chess club going
into the final round Grandmaster baarish
pullets had six points followed by GM
gorilla and test at five apiece in Group
B we have the winner of the entire field
Grandmaster Andre baarish poets an
amazing tournament you had with just the
exception of the hiccup in the seventh
round man five straight wins in the
middle of this thing what do you make of
it well thank you for relations uh uh
yeah it was really thoughtful woman for
me even though I managed to win games in
a row but like the finish of the
tournament was really hard for me
because we especially because of this
lost and my seventh round yeah when I
just messed up like everything in the
opening after that I I had very little
chance to just to save the game yeah and
still I don't know maybe like it took me
too much energy to Windows five games in
a row and make this explain why it
wasn't so smoothly in then but still
like all the opponents are electron and
definitely in this tournament you cannot
say like you you're definitely can win
like this guy and this guy draw so not
like that so each and every game you
need to work best as you can just try to
show your best yet yeah and I'm I'm
really just happy to to win
awkward you're gonna play Bishop perform
here which frankly I didn't like because
after 24 I was feeling that at this
point I can do only better so from now
on only white needs to be precise in
order not to ending up in a worse
position so clean c3 and once again
before I really like this idea because
just not allowing this Queen ancestry so
and hear ya maybe quantify for Queen d2
were some options however here it
doesn't seem dangerous for black upon k
so i can play rugby 8 for example yeah
did this should be just simply capably
but after Quinn 26 I was really
confident at this point that I'm not
going to lose this one for sure and
actually I was thinking of trying to
make some problems objective I'm sorry
for white because it's without clintus
it's not that obvious whether like what
i can hold this or not because the
endgame is clearly slightly better for
black a tree I think a normal movement
here I spend some time calculating moved
III this was another tempting option
which however riya I felt like shouldn't
be enough for a win for so black I don't
know maybe roots III or Bishop d3 so
there are some options for for--why so I
decided that a firefight is just simply
safer so of course the trees more
ambitious however at this point I had a
feelin that okay so maybe if I i miss
play something so i just can end up with
this week one so that's why i decided to
just simply go for a five and clearly
here is no risk for blood so f4 was a
possible move however i thought like
maybe maybe Bishop d3 I felt like was
another chance how are you
it should be just simply draw a shine
game for both sides so f4 or create
rugby six ya b3 maybe Ruby eight was
another option but he'll at this point
I'm not pretending to win this one
because there is kind of no penetration
for black through candy so this it just
should be simple draw so I was just
hoping for that kind of flying so after
route takes 38 rook c8 and I look like
my only chance to create some problems
with Bishop c4 and now it seems to me
that the only précisément for white skin
f1 and it should should end up in just a
simply draw which we can gain something
like this X equaling would be three yeah
after taking taken she should be drawn
so Ruby 6b three f5 f5 is just kind of a
normal option but anyway you just should
be drawn and here I felt like maybe rook
takes root G takes on this is much
better but he also not much to say about
this position should be just a job the
ship to 663 rotate be 300 here I offer
the draw which was accepted however like
after the game I was thinking like
whether I could play this one for away
me when item also so my first idea
presentation was something like this if
I uh I mean it's quite place you should
see for then I can take take and this
position might believe a little trickier
see because here there is simply not
many move for white to make so we see
five and i think this Abruzzi too and I
just can try to play these three verses
to which is of course objectively draw
however like the very last moment I
thought like my bikinis to is not that
clear and frankly I wasn't sure whether
this
is is ok but but now I just see that
this one also should be fine for black
for example and masami ridiculous life
like like this I believe that she should
be capably or I just decided to offer
soon as possible because like in the
time trouble you never know so we just
can you know was the control and that's
not what I wanted to so that is just
just just the right time to go for a job
oh yeah well and with that draw that's
enough to clinch Group B what's next for
you on the chest Orizon oh well I'm
going to play Final Four tournament just
any week or even less than a week so the
first round is going to be next Saturday
yeah not not much fun to the shield oak
tree and don't relax for too long well
Andre a very hearty congratulations
Spencer we have Grandmaster and rave
Irish poets the 2017 winter chess
classic Group B champion your force
placers alejandro ramirez and been fine
gold with four and a half points we'll
split the fourth place prize $1,000
third place Robert S net $1,500
christian corolla with six out of nine
will take home twenty five hundred
dollars and from ukraine the group be
champion andre bearish pullets with six
and a half points takes four thousand
dollars the 2017 winter chess classic is
in the books we had a lot of great games
played check them out on us chest champs
calm and remember this is only the
beginning for tournaments just like this
every year one per season for the st.
Louis chess club I'm Ben Simon so long
from the show me state